Çeviri: Efe Ersoy
Gözden geçirme: Sancak Gülgen
Bugün, hayatımın en güzel günü!
Today is the best day of my life.
C'est le plus beau jour de ma vie.
Yani bu anı yaşamayı bildiğin zaman
her an en güzel an oluyor.
Yani şimdiki zamanı yaşamayı öğrendim.
Yani sizlerle beraber burada olduğum
için çok mutluyum.
Ve sizleri tek tek seviyorum.
Ve sizler mükemmelsiniz!
Bunu söylemek biraz tuhaf geliyor şimdi.
Ama gerçekten kalbimden herkesi seviyorum.
Neden?
Bunu anlatacağım
bugün size.
Ve neden mükemmel olduğunuzu anlatacağım.
Nasıl?
Hayatımda birkaç deneyim ve rastladığım
inanılmaz insanların hikâyesiyle.
17 yaşındayım.
Amerika'ya gezi var.
Babamın yanına gidiyorum,
"Gidebilir miyim?"
"Tabi çocuğum, git."
"Ama ücreti var?"
"Tamam, çalış git!"
"Aaa, ama arkadaşların annesi
babası veriyor parayı falan?"
"Bizde öyle değil!"
Çalıştım, Amerika'ya gittim ve
çok önemli bir şey öğrendim:
Kendim çalışarak Amerika yollarını aştım.
Ve dünyanın yollarını aştım!
Ve tüm dünyayı halen uçuyorum.
Babam orada ilk kameramı hediye etti.
Bana teşekkür etmek için,
"Aferin" demek için.
Ve iki tutkum oldu: Gezi ve görüntü.
Fotoğraf ve yönetmenlik oldu
hayatım boyunca işim.
Geziyorum, çekiyorum.
Çekiyorum, paylaşıyorum.
Öyle devam ediyor.
Bir gün arkadaşlar:
"Gel Ouagadougouya gidelim" dedi.
Dedim "Ne bu ya? Ne atıyorsun?
Dalga mı geçme Afrikalılarla"
Gerçekten Ouagadougou diye bir
başkent olduğunu bilmiyordum!
Oraya gidiyoruz, o kadar fakirlik var ki!
Yani inanamıyorum, nasıl olur böyle?
Hiç görmemişim.
Yani fakir benim için Türkiye
idi o zamanlar.
Çünkü Fransa'da yaşıyorum,
Avrupa'da yaşıyorum.
Yani orayı görünce...
Dönünce, yani her gün yemek yediğim için,
her gün yıkanabildiğim için,
her gün yatakta yattığım için mutluyum...
O günden beri...
Başka bir şey öğrendim:
Bu Afrikalıların kalbi
o kadar zengin ki...
Ya hiçbir şeyleri yok;
her şeyini veriyor adam!
Ve kalbimi açmayı öğrendim!
Yolculuk devam ediyor,
bir gün Hindistan'dayım.
Orada zengin ülke ama
insanlar o kadar fakir ki...
Yani adamın önümde öldüğünü gördüm.
Yani öyle şey gördükten sonra...
Yani varlığa, çok şey olmasına
falan, yani...
Zor...
Kudüse gittim ve orada
değişik bir enerji var.
Dinlerin verdiği bir enerji.
Yani Hristiyan olsun, Yahudi olsun,
Müslüman olsun orada herkes inanıyor.
İnanarak oraya gidiyor ve
onları görüyorsun.
Orada tüm dinleri sevmeyi öğrendim.
Hırvatistan'dayız.
Orada otostop çekiyoruz.
Araba geçiyor durmuyor.
Mobilet geliyor, yalandan numara olsun
diye otostop çekiyoruz.
Ama iki kişiyiz alamaz bizi adam.
Böyle yapıyor, gidiyor, dönüyor.
Karşısına varıyoruz.
Oradan "Aslında benim 1,5 saat molam var
yemek yiyeceğim,
sen al mobileti git" diyor.
Tanımadığım adam!
Hayatımın en güzel mobilet gezisi oldu.
Yani ne öğrendim: "İnsanlara güvenin"
Orada motosikletini mi çalacağım adamın?
Çöle gittik, çekim yapıyoruz, belgesel.
Orada durum o kadar zor ki.
Yani bu pozisyonu güzel olsun diye yaptım
ama kafamda böyle bir pozisyon.
Yani kamerayı çantadan çıkarmak
o kadar zor ki.
Hava sıcaklığından, yürüyüşten,
şundan bundan...
Orada parmağımı kestim ve
Hasan diye şefimiz,
çünkü develerle gidiyoruz,
takip ediyoruz.
Ve bu adama söylüyorum:
"Parmağımı kestim"
Ona gösteriyorum, hiçbir şey demiyor.
Ya biz alışmışız karnımız ağrıyınca
anneye gideriz,
"Ah oğlum neyin var? Hap vereyim sana,
şunu vereyim, bunu vereyim ya uzan,
ya böyle, ya şöyle"
Adam bir şey demiyor!
Bir gün sonra anladım.
Yani parmağım kendi kendine kapanmış.
Ve orada değişik düşünmeyi öğrendim.
Yani bizim karnımız ağrıdığı zaman,
dünyalar bitiyor.
Ama aslında düşündüğün zaman
yani karnın ağrıdığı zaman
bir gün ağrır, iki gün ağrır,
o kadar!
Öyle düşününce onu unutmaya başlıyorsun
ve unutuyorsun.
Çok enterasan.
Afrika'ya gene gittik, Etiyopya,
belgesel çekimine gittik.
Beş bin yıl önceki gibi yaşayan insanlar.
Yani hiçbir şeyleri yok.
Yani binalar, ışıklar falan, düğmeye
basıyorsun bilmem ne,
hiçbir şeyden haberleri yok.
Sadece toprak ve hayvanlarla yaşıyorlar.
Orada, yani, biz o kadar bağlıyız ki
telefonlara, şuna, buna, arabaya, şu bu,
yani orada onlardan koptum.
Yani toprağa ve doğaya daha
yakın olmayı öğrendim.
400, geze geze 400 gezi yapmışım,
62 ülke gezmişim.
Değişik değişik düşünceler, değişik
dinler, değişik insanlara rastlamışım.
Ve bir sürü mükemmel
insanla karşılaşmışım.
Yani döne döne dedim bir dünya
turu yapsam nasıl olur?
Ve arkadaş buldum.
Ve parasız yaptık!
Nasıl olur?
Kimse inanmadı.
Yani 80 günde parasız pulsuz
dünya turu yapmak,
yani insanların bize yardım edeceğine
inanarak bu yolculuğa çıktık ama
tabi ki her gün kolay değil.
Yani çıkıyorsun parasız, ne yapacaksın?
Otostop yapıyoruz, nerede yiyeceksin?
nerede yatacaksın?
her gün başka yerde yatıyorsun,
yani her gün herkesle konuşuyorsun
ama yani zor bir durum.
Milan, arkadaşımla gittim bu geziye.
Optimistic Traveler diye bir isim
buldu bize arkadaşlar.
Sosyal medyadan attık, dedik: "Gideceğiz biz
dünya turuna, hangi ismi kullananalım?"
Optimistic Traveler: Güzel
Yönden Bakan Gezginler
Ve Milan'la Berlin'de tanışmıştık ve
bir test gezi yaptık beraber.
Gittik Berlin'e kadar Strazburg'dan ve
baktık ki yarış içindeyiz.
Yani ömür boyu yarış içindeyiz:
Okulda en iyisi olacaksın,
sporda en iyisi olacaksın,
devamlı en güzel olacaksın...
Yani bunu kırmak zor bir şey oldu.
Yani bir olalım ve bu dünya turunu yapalım
diye büyük çaba verdik ve
iyi ki yapmışız, kardeş gibi olduk ve
halen gezmeye beraber devam ediyoruz.
Dünya turu Paris'te başladı.
Ve Avrupa, Asya, Amerika
ve küçük bir Afrika’dan Marakeş,
Fas’dan geçtik.
İspanya ve döndük Paris’e.
Şimdi yolculuk başlıyor;
bütün Avrupa’yı geçtik,
Türkiye’yi de geçtik çok güzel,
misafirperver çok mutluyuz.
Muş’a vardık.
Muş’da otostop yapıyoruz araba duruyor,
belediye başkanı bizi düğüne götürüyor.
Dört yüz tane kişi harman da düğün yapıyor.
Köy düğünü falan süper.
Orada Türkü, Kürdü, Almanı, Fransızı
oynuyoruz, yemek yiyoruz.
Milan jonklörlük yapıyor orada,
paşalar gibiyiz.
Ama dünya turundayız yola
çıkmamız lazım, yola çıkıyoruz.
Bizi yola bırakıyorlar ve birden
tek başımıza yolda bekliyoruz.
Kimse bizi almıyor!
Yani çok inişli çıkışlı bir yolculuk.
İran’a varıyoruz.
Haberlere bakarsak sanki Fransa’dan İran’da
bütün İranlılar beraber bir
bomba yapıyorlar.
Oraya vardık baktık ki,
yani sizin bizim gibi
insanlar yaşıyor, ne güzel bir yer.
Ve bize Türkiye’de "kızlarla konuşmayın,
kırmızı kart alırsın,
hapishaneye gidersin,
tehlikeli kızlarla konuşma" dediler
ve Leyli ile rastladık.
Leyli eve gelin dedi bizde korktuk
dedik olur mu?
Eve vardık annesi ile tanıştırdı abisi
ile tanıştırdı, rahatladık ve
bizimle birlikte İsfahan’a kadar gitti.
İsfahan’da sufi arkadaş ile tanıştık:
İskender.
Ve sufi adamla Leyli, İran’da, bir kızla
aynı odada yerde dördümüz yattık.
Sima
Sima ile otobüste tanıştık,
beş dakika sonra annesini aradı
"İki gezgin var gelebilir miyiz" dedi
Kurban bayramını kutladık beraber.
Çok, en güzel anlarımızdan biri
çünkü orada hem dans ettik babası hacı,
dans ettik, oğlu türkü söyledi.
İran’da dans etmek
şarkı söylemek yasaktır.
Biz hepsini yapmışız.
Böyle güzel bir sofra serdiler yere,
hep beraber yemek yedik.
Yolculuk devam ediyor,
Pakistan’dan geçiyoruz.
Zor yerler, Afganistan’a yakın,
polisler götürüyor bizi, varıyoruz
Hindistan’da bu adamla karşılaşıyoruz
ve bize böyle bir şey söylüyor:
"Herkesin içinde Allah var" diyor.
Biz de düşünüyoruz diyoruz ki ya aslında
Allah’ı sevilecek kadar
herkesi sevebilirsek
ve herkes böyle herkesi severse
dünya bambaşka olur.
Enteresan bir şey.
Aynen Varanazi. Dere var orada,
Ganj Nehri.
Dünya’nın en pis derelerinden birisi.
Yani oraya kitaplarda parmağını
sokma diyorlar
ama bunlar ne diyor oraya girersen,
buna inanıyorlar,
bütün kötülüklerin çıkıyor,
iyilikle doluyorsun,
ve yeni doğmuş bebek gibi oluyorsun
ve ben denedim görmüş olduğunuz
gibi yeni doğmuş bebek gibiyim.
İftekar.
Onunla geziyoruz yemek yiyoruz,
zaman geçiriyoruz.
Gazeteye götürüyor sonra anlatıyor ki
bir sürü işi var.
Diyoruz ki sen bizimle nasıl bu kadar
zaman geçiriyorsun?
Diyor ki bizim için en önemlisi bir misafir
geldiği zaman ona zaman vermek.
Ve kafamda patlıyor, hayatımda
ne kadar zamanım yok,
zamanım yok, zamanım yok dediğim.
Daha bunu söylemiyorum, zamanım var.
Yolculuk devam:
Tayland, Malezya, Singapur.
Avrupa, Asya bitti, on dört ülke
16.000 km.
Yani Amerika bir dahaki etap.
İranlı aile ile karşılaşıyoruz, onlar
bizi otele götürmek istiyor.
"Davet ediyoruz, hoşumuza gitti
sizin geziniz" diyorlar.
Biz de "Evinize gitsek daha iyi olur,
yemek yeriz beraber,
Niye parasız? İnsanlarla beraber
olmak için bunu böyle yapıyoruz."
Olmaz ama tamam otele davet ediyoruz
diyorlar otele götürüyorlar,
Saray!
Hayatımda sarayda yatmadım.
Onu gördük dedik olmaz.
Biz trende böceklerle yattık,
İran’da banklarda yattık,
Tayland’da çimde yattık
yani böyle yerde yatmaya gerek yok.
Oradan dedi siz dinlenin.
Oradan isterseniz bize uçak bileti
için yardım edin dedik,
dedi siz dinlenin yarın
uçak biletini hallederiz.
Halletti, Amerika’ya vardık.
Jiby Hood'la karşılaştık.
Otel böyle!
Adamın o kadar büyük evi var ki
tuvalete gidecek, hangi tuvalete
gideceğini şaşırıyor.
Ama o öncedendi, şimdi küçük
bir ev aldı ve mutlu.
Yani sadece parayla mutlu olunmuyor.
Ve Jiby Hood arabanın anahtarını
verdi lüks araba,
arabaya bindik geziyoruz ve
acıkmaya başladık.
Milan’a bakıyorum ne yemek yiyeceğiz
şimdi paramız yok,
ama lüks arabanın içindeyiz.
Oradan Jiby Hood ile 3 gün
beraber geçirdik.
Ve gitmeden önce "Artık babanızım, hayatta
bir şey yapmadan önce beni arayın,
yardımcı olurum size" diyor.
Nasıl olur? Üç gün birisiyle olup da
böyle bir şey demesi.
Yani bizim arkadaş edinmek için
yıllar gerekiyor.
Bu adam nasıl böyle bir şey diyebilir.
Yani bu gezide insan ilişkilerinin çok
çabuk olduğunu vurgulamak istedim.
Salt Lake City’de üşümeye başladık.
Denver’a vardık -26,
dışarıda kalamıyorum.
Otobüse biniyorum
bu hanımı görüyorum.
Ve kafamda diyorum
Ben dışarıda kalamadım bir dakika
bu dışarıda yaşıyor.
Nasıl olur, kimse yok mu buna
yardım etmek için?
Ve hayalim oldu daha evsiz
olmasın bu dünyada.
Ama dedim biraz zor bu iş.
Strazburg’tan geliyorum ve
bu işe başladım,
Strazburg'ta evsiz olmasın diye
iki tane evsizi takip ediyorum
ve inşallah sene sonunda onlara
ev ve iş bulacağız.
Altı bin kişi yardım ediyor
Facebook’tan bize.
Jomy’lerle tanıştık ve onula
Haiti’ye gittik,
7.300 dolar topladık orada
okullara yardım ettik.
Melisa, trende gördük,
Melisa ile trende tanıştık ve...
Aslında gülünecek gibi
bir şey değil ama
Konuştuk falan, yattık uyuduk
çünkü tüm gece gidiyor tren.
Sabah uyandık mektup bıraktı
ve mektubun içine ne yazdı:
"Ben ölüme gidiyordum bu trenle,
sizinle karşılaştığım için
kararımı değiştirdim’ dedi.
Yani onu kurtarmak için bu dünya
turunu ne yaptıysak ne mutlu bize.
Sevil bizi Birleşmiş Milletler’e götürdü.
Yani binlerce insan bize yardım etti.
Yani bu insanlar mükemmel değil mi?
Siz de mükemmelsiniz, siz biliyorsunuz
mükemmel olduğunuzu.
Sizden daha iyi kim biliyor?
Ne kadar iyi insan olduğunu biliyorsun,
ne kadar iyi şeyler yaptığını biliyorsun.
Ve düşünüyorsun devamlı ben bunu
çok iyi biliyorum insanlar niye görmüyor?
Ama sizin mükemmel
olduğunuz kadar
başkalarının da mükemmel
olduğunu unutmayın.
Ve kendinizi mükemmel
tarafı bulmaya ayarlayın.
Bunu başardık, yaptık,
kimse inanmadı.
Önce inanmadı sonra inanamadı,
hala inanmıyor.
Ama bunu başardık yaptık.
Yani bu, ne demek oluyor?
Bu dünya turu parasız pulsuz
oluyorsa her şey olabilir.
Ve herkes hayalinin sonuna
gitmesi gerekiyor.
Ve inşallah hepiniz hayallerinizin
sonuna gideceksiniz.
Küçük bir hikaye ile bitirmek istiyorum.
Afrika'da bir gezgin bir araştırmacı
bir meyve hazırlıyor,
ve bu meyveyi ortaya koyuyor ve
çocuklara söylüyor
o ağaca kadar koşun, ilk elleyen
tüm meyveleri kazanacak.
Çocuklar el ele tutuşup dans ederek
yavaş yavaş şarkı söyleyerek
hep beraber o ağacı elliyorlar.
Dönüyorlar hep beraber o meyvenin
etrafında oturuyorlar ve paylaşıyorlar.
Araştırmacı "Ne yaptınız?"
Bunlar "Ubuntu" diyor.
Benim mutluluğum sizin
mutluluğunuza bağlı!
Teşekkür ederim.